E
PURPOSE, RIGHT?
YOU CAN WALK RIGHT AROUND THAT
LITTLE SECTION.
STEVE: LET'S BRING IN WISCONSIN
SENATOR RON JOHNSON MEMBER OF
THE SENATE HOMELAND SECURITY
COMMITTEE.
SENATOR, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
AINSLEY: GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING, GUYS.
STEVE: HEY, WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF
KAMALA HARRIS' TRIP TO -- HER
PHOTO OP. LAST WEEK IN EL PASO?
SHE WAS CRITICIZED BY
REPUBLICANS FOR NOT BEING AT THE
RIGHT SPOT.
YOU SAY YOU WERE ACTUALLY WHERE
SHE SHOULD HAVE GONE.
>> THEY TOOK HER TO A POINT IN
THE WHERE SHE WOULDN'T SEE THE
CRISIS SO THE PRESS WOULDN'T
REPORT ON THE CRISIS.
OF COURSE, THAT'S WHAT'S BEEN
GOING ON.
BRIAN, YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
I OFFERED AN AMENDMENT TO FORCE
THE ADMINISTRATION TO ACTUALLY
BUILD THE 250 MILES OF WALL
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR $2 BILLION.
EVERY DEMOCRAT EXCEPT JOE
MANCHIN VOTED AGAINST THAT
AMENDMENT.
AGAIN, WHAT THEY HAVE GOTTEN
GOOD AT.
THEY HAVE GOTTEN VERY EFFICIENT
AT PROCESSING AND DISPERSING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY ARE TAKING CREDIT FOR THAT
FUELING THE CRISIS.
EXACERBATING THE PROBLEM.
BRIAN: TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
THOSE THROWN OUT DURING THE
TRUMP YEARS WERE EVALUATED TO
NOT BE WORTHY OF ADMISSION HERE.
THEY ARE BEING CALLED BACK BY
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
WE URGE YOU TO REAPPLY TO COME
HERE.
UNDER WHAT SCHOOL OF THOUGHT IS
THAT A GOOD IDEA?
>> IT'S NOT A GOOD IDEA.
YOU SIMPLY CAN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS DOING WE
LITERALLY ARE APPREHENDED 6,000
PEOPLE PER DAY.
THAT'S A LARGE CARAVAN EVERY DAY
BEING PROCESSED OTHERS BEING
RETURNED.
OTHERS DISPERSED.
THIS CRISIS SNOFT GOING AWAY.
UNDER EVERYBODY'S RADAR BECAUSE
THE PRESS ISN'T COVERING IT.
AINSLEY: YOU HELD AN EVENT
TALKING ABOUT THE VACCINE AND
YOU CAME UNDER SOME FIRE FOR IT
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
THAT HAVE TAKEN THE VACCINE AND
THEY HAVE HAD ADVERSE REACTIONS
TO IT.
WE HAVE A ANOTHER, A SOUNDBITE
FROM THAT EVENT.
A MOTHER SHE HAS A 12-YEAR-OLD
DAUGHTER.
SHE VOLUNTEERED TO TAKE THE
PFIZER VACCINE DURING THE
CLINICAL TRIALS.
AND THE CHILD NOW IS IN A
WHEELCHAIR.
LISTEN TO THIS MOTHER.
[[INAUDIBLE]]
IBLE.
AINSLEY: IN CASE YOU COULDN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT SHE WAS SAYS.
HER DAUGHTER HAS BEEN TO THE ER
NINE TIMES.
HOSPITALIZED THREE TIMES FOR A
TOTAL OF THREE MONTHS.
YOU CAN SEE HER EMOTION.
YOUR REACTION?
>> FIRST OF ALL, EVERYBODY THAT
WE HAD AT THAT EVENT IS
PRO-VACCINE.
THREE OF THEM ACTUALLY
PARTICIPATED IN THE TRIALS.
THE DRUG COMPANIES HAVE LARGELY
ABANDONED THEM.
BUT THAT WAS STEPHANIE, HER
DAUGHTER IS MADE.
THINK OF HOW SHE FEELS, SHE WAS
GIVEN ASSURANCE THIS IS
INCREDIBLY SAFE BUT HER DAUGHTER
HAS SUFFERED SEVERE NEUROLOGICAL
PROBLEMS LIKE THE OTHER FOUR
WOMEN AS WELL.
THEY HAVE BEEN SUFFERING THESE
PROBLEMS FOR MONTHS.
THE C DID.
C AND NIH ARE IGNORING THEM.
THE DRUG COMPANIES ARE IGNORING.
THEY ALL THEY WANTED WAS TO BE
SCENE AND HEARD AND BELIEVED SO
THEY CAN GET TREATMENT AND CURED
AND HOPEFULLY RAISE THE ISSUE SO
THAT OTHERS WON'T BE SIMILARLY
HARMED.
STEVE: YEAH.
JOE BIDEN IS GOING TO GO
WISCONSIN TODAY TO TALK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
YOU AND THE OTHER REPUBLICANS
ARE FOR REAL INFRASTRUCTURE BUT
THE DEMOCRATS ARE FOR THE KIND
OF INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS SOCIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AOC, I THINK, YESTERDAY SAID
YEAH, WE NEED BRIDGES BUT WE
ALSO NEED BABYSITTERS.
>> WELL, WHAT DEMOCRATS WANT TO
DO IS CREATE MORE LONG-TERM
ENTITLEMENTS THAT CAN NEVER BE
TURNED DOWN.
CAN NEVER BE REDUCED, THAT WILL
COMPLETELY MORTGAGE OUR
CHILDREN'S FUTURE.
REPUBLICANS ARE ABSOLUTELY FOR
BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE.
HERE'S THE DEAL THAT THEY HAVE
ON THE TABLE RIGHT NOW.
RE-PURPOSE THE $700 BILLION FROM
THE LAST $1.9 TRILLION AIR COVID
RELIEF PACKAGE ISN'T BEING SPENT
2022 TO 202.
$7 BILLION WOULD BE MORE THAN
ENOUGH.
HAVE THAT PASSED LITERALLY IN A
COUPLE DAYS.
THEY JUST REJEC